after delivering a stunning finale to
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy Trilogy
James Gunn has proven that he knows how
to handle Cosmic Heroes with complex
emotions and that's exactly what
Superman needs right now some spoilers
for Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 ahead
James Gunn's appointment as the head of
DC Cinematic Universe seemed logical the
director had made some of Marvel's best
films with the Guardians of the Galaxy
series and he delivered the most
acclaimed DC movie in years The Suicide
Squad in 2021 but you might wonder why
Gunn would choose to write and direct a
new Superman movie himself the character
has been hard to adapt for the big
screen in the modern era and Henry
cavill's version though popular with
some fans didn't last gun also has a
knack for witty sarcasm that suits
Guardians of the Galaxy but might clash
with the Man of Steel so the question
remains is gun the right choice to
direct a Superman movie that's a good
question after watching Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 the answer is a clear yes
though the two franchises differ in
style and tone volume 3 shows how good
gun is at the things that count
character development emotional
resonance and heart amidst all the humor
and colorful alien settings the movie
returns to what made the MCU great
honoring both its Heroes and the time
fans have spent with them in short
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 has sold
us on James Gunn's Superman Legacy movie
Superman's bright outfit catchy name and
dedication to helping those in need set
the standard for everything that
followed including the modern comic book
Blockbuster industry but the world of
caped Comic characters has changed a lot
since then it's not enough to just save
people anymore you need over-the-top
enemies a Multiverse and countless
crossovers maybe it's the Simplicity of
his costume or his Swiss army knife
Powers but Superman has managed to stay
above the noise and still represents the
spirit of those Golden Days Clark Kent
is known for being good and kind and
brave and true even in the darkest of
times he does the right thing which is
why we love superheroes in the first
place Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
understands that message it's accurate
in its portrayal of what makes its
Heroes heroic in the film's Final Act
the team fights through a whole ship of
bad guys not to kill the main villain or
find the last infinity stone but to save
the many Innocents trapped there kids
aliens baby animals every single life
matters and they all get out alive after
nearly a decade of action-packed
climaxes and battles against Thanos and
his ilk the Guardians end their Trilogy
by Saving Lives not doing stunts and
that's what Superman is all about
Marvel Studios has had plenty of hits
since the infinity Saga ended including
Loki black panther wakanda Forever and
One Division
what is grief
love
persevering but there have also been
more than a few Duds at its worst the
franchise has become a focus-tested
mishmash of setups Easter eggs and spot
The Cameo moments fortunately Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 is the good kind of
Marvel movie one that focuses on real
character development instead of cheap
callbacks volume 3 Cashes in on nine
years of build up we get to see nebula
become an inspiring leader after a
tragic rage-filled life rocket overcomes
his immense trauma and finally accepts
himself as he is these arcs work because
of how much time we've all spent with
the characters though he's a larger than
life figure Superman needs that same
kind of attention the character fails
when he's treated as less than a person
and more than a god a Titanic emblem of
goodness with no actual Arc to speak of
the appeal of Kalel is that he chooses
to be Superman time after time even
though he could just as easily conquer
all of Earth in an instant additionally
Superman needs to stand on his own apart
from any other sub-series or justice
league teammates if if he is to be the
heart of gun's new DCU it needs to be a
heart that beats and bleeds and not just
a logo
though they're still silly more often
than they're not the Guardians of the
Galaxy films may also be the most
emotionally complex in all of the MCU
each one of the main characters is
deeply flawed and haunted by the ghosts
of their pasts over the course of the
story they're all forced to confront
their traumas ultimately finding new
things to fight for and ways to improve
themselves Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
continues with that Trend giving the
team an emotionally resonant send-off
that is the gist of it Gunn's ability to
handle messy characters and emotionally
muddled storylines makes him a great
choice for the DCU and for Superman in
particular Clark Kent might seem like a
much more sunshine and Rainbow's
character than other DC heroes like
Batman or John Constantine but telling
his story the right way requires an
understanding of the complicated world
around him he too is a man born of
tragedy shipped away from his family and
his entire home planet while just a baby
out of that tragedy and with the
guidance of some compassionate adoptive
parents he discovers the drive to help
the helpless wherever they might be
Superman's strength is born of grief
just like the Guardians of the Galaxy
hopefully gun's strong track record of
writing nuanced comic book character
arcs will parlay into a fantastic Man of
Steel film
few details have been revealed about
James Gunn's Superman movie which is set
to be released in 2025. however the
writer director has dropped a couple of
Clues speaking about the script on
Twitter in March of 2023 Gunn said that
the story will largely focus on
Superman's Heritage how both his
aristocratic Kryptonian parents and his
Kansas farmer parents inform who he is
and the choices he makes what exactly
does that have to do with Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 well a lot actually
consider Rocket's Arc in the third
Guardians film he has to deal with a
violent and complicated history in order
to become the hero he knows he can be
sound familiar how about nebula and
Gamora who both have to Grapple with
their dark upbringing by Thanos in order
to take ownership of their lives for his
entire comic book movie career Gunn has
been telling stories about how our
history shapes us about how it
determines our paths and the ways we can
break away from it from the sound of it
Gunn's Superman Legacy will be as much
about Krypton as Earth for a director
who's built his reputation on the backs
of sci-fi superhero move movies that
makes a lot of sense of course the two
will still be quite different with gun
telling Rolling Stone in April 2023 it's
not like Superman is going to have
exactly the same Vibe as a Guardians
movie it's actually quite different we
still have a while to wait before gun
Superman Vision becomes clear the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 is a
strong endorsement of what the director
could be cooking up